hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of the 2018 World
rapid championship we have an excellent
game between one cow and the Russian
Grand Master Donnell dubov before we get
to the game I do want to share a very
interesting story Peter like I mentioned
it in the live broadcast I don't know of
how many of you were able to catch it
but like I said that when he was 8 years
old he is a colleagues from well
colleagues teammates from the same chess
club that were older than him played a
little joke on him they told him that
they read in a in a Soviet chess
magazine that that from now on it's
considered that castling is a waste of
time and that he should not castle in
his games and he said that he was like
he didn't know what to make of it and I
mean to play such a cruel trick on on an
eight-year-old boy I mean they did tell
him they were joking immediately but
still I thought you know what a nice
sense of humor a chess sense of humor if
you will but getting back to this game
it's a it's a game from around 14 so Du
Bois having an excellent tournament so
far without losing a single game faces a
very strong Grandmaster Wang Hao and
Knight f3 is used to open the ready
opening Knight to f6 we have c4 g6 g3
and the Bishop to g7 we have rush up to
G to C 6 and now d4 we have d5 Knights
to d2 we have castles and castles also
by white a 5 B 3 and now comes Knight to
e4 our black is hoping to the trade of
the Knights here so the the pawn can be
used to take away the night from f3 and
here we have Bishop to b2 white simply
continues developing and Bishop to f5
it's a it's a nice square for the bishop
but of course it's not gonna be able to
stay there very long we have nice to h4
attacking the bishop and now black is
well the decides to capture on d2 Knight
captures Queen captures and if now comes
the bishop the back to e6 seems like an
odd Square for the bishop blocking its
own east 7 phone but it's not really
that big of a deal
we have F for preparing f5 and
disposition was reached a few more times
there are a couple of games in the
database with this exact same position
and most of the moves that the black
decided to play here was to prevent
white from pushing f5 so f5 is a known
move here Queen to d7 is a known move
here and also stalling some a time with
D captures on c4 but here dubov plays
Knight to d7 it's a new move that was
not played before he actually allows
that five but nice to the d7 is a
strongest move recommended by the engine
so as this is move twelve I think it's
safe to assume that dubov is still
within his opening preparation and that
he really came prepared to this game at
five I mean who wouldn't play this G
captures on f5 Knight captures we have
Bishop captures rook captures and now e6
simply kicking away the rook you might
yeah of course you would enjoy if you
could stay for example somewhere along
these lines to be able to join the
attack against the black king but if you
go rogue g5 okay you you're not gonna
fall to rush up to 86 as the BB spin but
after f5 that rook is pretty much stuck
there the Queen will have to stay there
to guard the rook and if you play h4 and
then black can simply move the King and
it will be very hard to get your look
out of there so after each six we have
rook F to F 1 sorry rook F back to F 1
and now black decides to go for f5 and
here we have this very nice Stonehenge
structure which is well most of the
times very safe for black even though
the King side structure is a bit
compromised C capture some d5 we have
seek after Sandefur and now comes rook a
to c1 taking a hold of the only open a
file on the board Knight to f6 the e4
square is an excellent square for the
Black Knight Bishop to f3 not allowing
ideas like perhaps knife to h5 and then
pushing the f4 with a 4 by white a 4 by
white sari a 4 by black
yeah a 4 by black trying to go crack
open a whites Queen side Queen to e3 and
going out
blacks east exponent now comes Queen to
d7 defending d6 pawn rook to c2 and now
a capture some v3 queen capture some b3
and now comes Luke a to c8 countering
the white rook and C to rook F to c1 and
now we have butter to h6 attacking the
rook here either asking why do you want
to play III maybe and then I will trade
rooks here or do you want to capture
rooks immediately white decides to trade
immediately with rook captures on c8
rook captures on c8 and now rook the c5
now white well it's not really dead a
dangerous if black captures and c5 but
if white captures here then you could
imagine a scenario it is a rapid game
you know time is of the essence so
perhaps some a4 a5 a6 ideas will be
possible where maybe white can sacrifice
upon it and create a past C pawn but
black decided not to go for this the
rook station C 5 and we have Bishop to
f8 kicking the the rule back we have
looked a b5 now with a double attack
against the b7 pawn rook to c7 defending
and now comes look to b6 putting
pressure against the e6 pawn and there
are some there is some poison to the
position if you're not careful if you
play a move like let's say you move
Knight to a weird Square like the g4
then you might fall to an idea like rook
captures on e6 and Queen captures the
Bishop captures here wins the Queen so
okay after rope to b6 we have Knight to
e4 it's a too powerful square for the
knight so you do have to eliminate it
Bishop captures we have F captures on e6
and now comes King to g2 and okay Bishop
to g7 here we have this position where
black is pretty much stuck regarding the
b7 pawn and but on the other hand if if
black is able to activate the pieces
then black should be better as the
whites dark square bishop on v2 isn't
really doing all that much and okay we
have looked to be 5 by white maybe I'm
going for ideas like rook to c5 to trade
rooks and now comes Queen to f7 and here
black is hoping as all of whites pieces
are
basically concentrating on the queenside
he's hoping for rook to h6 this will
control the e3 square he wants to pull
this pawn to e3 this will control the f2
square and of course he wants to bring
the Queen over to f2 so how will white
go about this one such one such move
that would be great would be Queen to
III not allowing this Bishop to e6 move
black would still have a better position
here but white would at least be able to
fight here after this screen to f7 move
we have looked a b6 but now after Bishop
286 it's very hard for whites to play
this game you wanna defend against such
a scenario so white rice Queen to d1 now
trying to go for Queen to f1 and trading
Queens and the wall here you could go
pawn to e3 as planned Bishop to e3 that
was played in the game is even better so
now comes Queen to f1 offering to trade
Queens and now if you capture King
captures you'd still be better but you'd
still be a long way of claiming this as
anything anything that can be pushed for
a whip but here
Donald will have decided to go Queen to
h5 and now you have you have a lot of
troubles here the thread is rook to f7
to f2 Queen Queen to h2 of course so a
lot of a lot of threats here we have
rook captures on ie6 but there isn't
really a better move and now comes Luke
- see - and hear me you can see that
white is in a lot of trouble the bishop
on b2 is under attack and there's no
good way to to defend really if you
allow rook captures I mean - the Queen
is protecting that pawn you could easily
imagine being checkmated on h2 and here
king - h1 is played not allowing this
rook captures I need you to come with
checkmate but if you tried this you
would this is actually a trick if if you
do both try to route captures on e2 it
seems like there is no way to protect
against Queen captures on h2 checkmate
because the rook is protected the bishop
is controlling in these two squares but
you would actually allow white a defense
with rook to e8 now you cannot go down
with a king because of Queen to f8 you
would have to capture and then white
gets the couch
the rook and now it's pretty much a
dronin game with the black king being so
open white will always be able to
continue checking the black king so here
King to h1 and was played but here do or
simply play to look out for some b2 and
now the bow is up a whole piece and
there isn't much white can do here we
have route 3 5 attacking the Queen but
now Queen to f7 now of course your upper
piece you want to trade Queen's route to
f5 attacking the Queen we have Queen to
e6 getting out of the way
this allows the rook to a fate check but
rook to f8 check doesn't do anything I
mean you're just gonna move the King
King g7 and there are no more checks and
if you move the Queen if you prepare
anything
then then well you're gonna fall to look
to be 1 checked but here after this
Queen to e6 move we have work to eat 5
again attacking the Queen Queen back to
d7 and here Queen to f6 was played
hoping to get some sort of an attack
here but it is far too late for such
things so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the winning idea
for black it's a forced checkmate
so it's it's not a very difficult one as
we've already mentioned it briefly but
you know do pause the video and try to
figure it out for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
actual excellent listener as I already
mentioned it this move but it's you know
very important to see that the queen is
covering the h3 square so Brooke to be 1
check this was played in the game and it
was in this position that one haw
resigned the game because after you can
either start giving up material but
would keep the g2 you get root 2 G 1 and
this is now checkmate as well these two
scores are covered by the bishop and the
pawn and you have to see that the queen
is covering the h3 squares so this is
checkmate so yeah like we said this was
a game from round 14 a very nice and a
very important victory for Donald obove
as it was with the black pieces so
everyone thought that he's going into
the last round as the favorite in the
last round
Donald over-faced Sharma Arif but he
again had the black pieces against mum
but among media of played a very very
quick draw against him so it was a very
intense last round of the 2018 World
rapper championship before I forget here
are the here are the results after round
15 let me just fix that a bit there
there we go so yeah yeah there you can
see Donal dubov winning the 2018 World
rapid championship the only only player
with 11 points then we have a lot of
players with with 10 and a half not a
lot for players sharma media of Hikaru
Nakamura Vladislav artemiev and the
Magnus Carlsen Carlton faced Nakamura in
the final round of the 2018 world rapid
and well Nakamura tried playing a
psychological trick on Carlsen as
Nakamura had the white pieces and he
quickly went for a line where Carlson
could either choose to go into a very
draw a Shen game or or go into worst
possession calls and decided to go into
the draw a Shen game and there was no no
way to push for anything therefore for
knock or for Carlson so that game ended
in a draw without giving chances to
either of them for a shot at the title
and it's very interesting there you have
ali reza fury lucia who had a
spectacular tournament almost going all
the way but as you can see the the
iranian grandmaster won a hundred and
fifty 7.4 rating points which is i think
the most that anyone won in this
tournament so quite an achievement then
you have you jungie
onigiri onigiri has never met up with
Magnus Carlsen in this tournament that
was a very anticipated encounter due to
their you know a little skirmishes on
Twitter but you know who knows we will
have a lot of rounds of blitz so I think
everyone will meet up with everyone
certainly a car a Segway car can also
with a nice finish 10 points then Tigran
lavona which petrosyan Anton gorev of
Maxime at La Cava consists of Duda David
Anton Alexander Grisha also with 10
points
demetria Covino pavel from crowd of
those with 10 points and then a lot a
lot of player with players with 9 and a
half points you can see you have
nine and nine and a half out of 15 but
you are already at 19th place that's
that's the the strength of this
tournament one cow who lost this game to
Donnell dubov Alexandra Zulu Grigory
opening gata Kamsky beef Manhattan
Island also on nine and a half he was
the defending champion but it it was not
his tournament but even I mean nine and
a half in this competition and from 15
rounds is an excellent result
Kiril Alex & Co and Daniel Friedman also
good nine and half those are the first
25 players so we are only going to show
those but via I mean just you go to
chess results.com and you can check out
how everyone everyone played sir now
congratulations to Daniel dubov on such
a spectacular tournament he didn't lose
a single game and interestingly he he
drew his game against Magnus Carlsen it
was a fairly quick draw but still quite
quite an accomplishment and yeah as the
title suggests in Magnus Carlsen didn't
not announce who were his seconds for
the world championship match against
Fabiana Caruana and Donnell double was
one of the secret seconds who was
helping him prepare for the match and
who were who was preparing him during
the match and when they asked Donald
above in an interview after the game you
know what are his thoughts on this
entire tournament and winning the first
place and everything he said aetna
nothing special I don't think he he was
still like feeling what just happened
but he doesn't seem very impressed by
that it's like a very down-to-earth
fellow it seems but yeah also he
mentioned that during this time he was
preparing Carlsen before and after the
match and during the match it seems that
he said that in a in a joking fashion
that it seems that Carson prepared him
too much and that you know the winning
first place here it definitely shows
what what what a great stuff it was a
training with the world champion but
yeah yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I will try and do some other
games from this championship gonna check
out the the women's section of the
rapids as well
or some of the games from there I would
like to thank Ali Shariati Cody Johnson
Seymour butts Seminole Johnson and union
grass Danny for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you all and I will see you
soon